how minor math their least favorite
fashion moment Alexis Michelle you win
the club picture oh I think this is the
perfect outfit to be waiting at the
doctor's office I think I saw it
somewhere under a fur coat it was blue
kind of Grecian there was some real like
basic mall shoes that was not a great
fashion moment
Nina Bonino was how am I being laughing
the crazy dead face I mean she made an
amazing job on her makeup but girl the
fishnets on the course and let courser
well it was my princess disaster like
that was like my least favorite because
it landed me in the bottom I mean there
was a lot of questionable choices this
season a lot of great choices but that
one I was so confident about it and I'm
mad at it I burned it and I left it
behind
I'm not gonna say nothing J no man tells
Callie I'm at Ahana living in Milwaukee
Wisconsin landed Sierra cheese and
serial killers she's a Dairy Queen now
it's real crime
James Mansfield white party I couldn't
stand it I hate shoes like that a real
crime against humanity American crime
story even up my least favorite fashion
moment of it even with my own we had to
do something called 999 tea and I just
wasn't quite sure this was something
that I should have had handmade and done
by a couturier or should order it on
Amazon for $7 and which one do you think
I did ladies and gentleman it was on
prime yeah it got there in one day huge
mistake
peppermint naughty nightie look which
I'm partially responsible for I gave her
the lace gloves and the
tiny thong which is why it looks so
small on earth we can blame her my fault
but also it was yeah it was a rough spot
I really loved my pilgrim look for home
state so I was dressed as a pilgrim and
I did a tearaway it was really hard to
get up and looked really awkward and
pathetic and I still have nightmares
because late Oh Lady Gaga talked to me
she said you should really practice
ripping that thing off and I thought
Gaga is giving me advice about ripping
stuff off such an excellent choice then
makeover challenge and watching my
daughter bake cool a completely flop on
the runway and that was my ball I